another busy day I've gotta go off to
fight hockey now then we're going to
have our Chinese New Year lunch at the
office I hope to get back and do a
little bit of Korean having given up on
the Vancouver Canucks I'll watch them a
bit on TV or gonna have some dinner a
busy day I better get started see you
later mind you this is picking up my
office chinese new year lunch so I come
to The Times restaurant straight from
hockey
I
boys do yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah y'all done I think I go see karate
all rights chinese new year and we're
gonna we're having a Chinese New Year
lunch here at the office that is KP
would wear in lumber we have you know
software for the lumber industry and
language and always kind of stuff and we
have our staff and so I'm going to turn
this around and we're all gonna say
something in a language either our own
language or language of our choice
please just eat innova pagina de cuello
I came estimate altimas gung hay fat
choy please and your new ever wave of
you able 1 Arnold did everything happy
new year I know that one Louis all do
they do it uh you've got a funny
regional accent on that I could normally
I understand that no I'm gonna miss ya
oh my god is able bond you out his head
and back to me here are gonna check hey
cheese it's just me Nova doc now all of
you have to guess what these languages
were and dark you later I'm finally back
at the office and hope to settle down
and do a bit of Korean studying up
strong a few things here um I guess you
know today as I say it was a busy day
only now I have it haven't got time to
do something although obviously in the
car driving to the office and driving a
pickup by the Chinese lunch and then
driving home I was listening um just a
couple of observations first of all I
want to make it very clear that i didn't
start korean from scratch number of
people are saying gee your tremendous
you know for two weeks no seven or eight
years ago I studied Korean for about six
months listening and reading
you know an hour they on and off kind of
thing and then probably two or three
years ago I was in Japan on lumber and i
bought some Korean books some of those
Japanese Korean books have shown you and
so I spent some time with them I've also
done a fair amount of reading of Korean
at link often on sporadically so I don't
come it you know come at my Korean from
nothing my goal here in three months is
to see how far I can move it forward
with this extra push this challenge this
greater intensity okay so I'm not
pretending them from a standing start
scratch position I'm going to reach some
exalted level in the language all I want
to do is improve now the interesting
thing is despite all the listing that
I've done and then of course I leave it
for a number of years because I'm doing
check or Russian and so forth I think
that as I start up again I very quickly
get back to the level that I was at that
that recovery is is very quick however
despite over two weeks of listening and
reading when I listen to things that I
haven't listened to for a while my
comprehension isn't noticeably better I
think I have a better sense than ever of
the definitions that the starting and
ending of the words I know what words
people are saying in some cases I know
the meaning of the word but I'm not
putting it all together into meaning and
the sort of improvement in that ability
is not quick and I mentioned that
because I think it's important to be
realistic first of all I consider the
goal is comprehension it's not difficult
to get to where you can say something in
the language and even say it quite well
and sound as if you speak the language
but if you don't understand what people
are saying back to you that you can't
really engage in any kind of meaningful
conversation and being meaningful is
very important to me so I want to get my
comprehension up but that is a slow
process and I know from experience that
it takes a long time people sometimes
say to me you know I've been studying
Spanish for so many years and I have
trouble understanding movies or
understanding soap operas and stuff it
takes a long
time to train the brain at least for my
brain maybe some people go faster but
the fact that people can spout some
phrases in a language doesn't and I
include myself in that I can spout
phrases in Korean it doesn't mean that I
understand it and the understanding
takes lots of exposure for it to improve
but it eventually does improve and
you'll have these Eureka moments where
you understood everything or a lot and
and so those are the moments that make
it worthwhile but when shouldn't be too
anxious for quick results because for
most people when it comes to
comprehension and comprehension is that
is the base when it comes to
comprehension it takes time